-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
I'm about to have a dance battle
against a very worthy opponent.
Please welcome JoJo Siwa!
Wow, look at you.
Come on now.
-Hey!
-Why would I even do this?
-I'm ready.
I'm ready for "Dance Battle."
-Here's how it works.
This is the dance-move
generator here,
and I'm going to hit the button,
which will randomly select
a never-before-scene dance move.
So that could be my advantage.
These are not done.
These aren't famous moves.
Whoever's turn it is has to make
up a dance for that move,
and the best dancer will win.
Let's start
the dance-move generator!
-Alright, what am I gonna get?
-The "glitter on my sweater."
-What does it say?
-Alright, alright, alright.
-Alright, here we go.
Can we get some music?
♪♪
-Alright.
Let's go, music.
♪♪
-See, she's dancing.
She just owns it. Come on now.
Alright.
Oh, wait a second. Oh, what?
She actually -- Oh, come on.
See?
Alright, that's not bad.
-Oh, oh, oh, oh!
-Not bad. I like that.
Alright. I'll take that.
Here we go. Alright.
I'll take that.
-I like the little flick.
-Yeah, I like the flip too.
I've never seen the flip before.
But I don't wear epaulets
all the time, but okay.
Alright, JoJo, it is my turn.
-That makes one of us.
These are a daily occurrence
for me.
[ Both laugh ]
-Let's start the generator.
The "bartender who does
too much." Hmm.
-Well, let's see it.
-Alright, the "bartender
who does too much."
Okay. Here we go.
♪♪
-I got you, I got you,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
♪♪
Oh, oh, come on, come on!
Show us how to make it! Yeah!
♪♪
Oh, my God.
-They just wanted --
They just wanted a beer,
that's all.
He did too much, you see?
[ Laughs ]
-I liked you. You were getting
your teppanyaki work in there.
You were throwing it
and you were cooking it.
-He was flipping it
behind the back.
He was going for it. Turns out
he was like, "Oh, a beer?"
-I love it.
-[ Exhales deeply ]
Alright, Grandpa's
gonna catch his breath. JoJo.
-It's okay, it's okay.
You did good.
-Let's start the generator
for you.
-Let's do it.
That was full out, Jimmy.
-The "just dropped my phone
and I hope it didn't crack."
That's happened to me before.
Never on the dance floor.
-Oh, boy.
-But let's see.
"I just dropped my phone
and I hope it didn't crack."
Okay. JoJo.
-I think I need a prop.
I got a TV remote.
This is gonna be my phone.
-[ Laughs ]
Alright, perfect. Here we go.
JoJo, when you're ready,
let's start the music.
♪♪
Alright, you're on the phone.
Yeah. Oh, oh! Oh.
♪♪
Oh, subtle. Very subtle.
-It didn't crack!
It didn't crack!
We're good! We're good!
-[ Laughs ]
-Ah, I did lose my bow
and my ear. Hold on. Hold on.
-I loved the subtlety.
-My phone didn't crack.
I lost a bow, I lost an ear,
but my phone did not crack.
That's all that matters.
-No, I loved the subtlety of
like, "Oh, I'm still dancing."
Then you go, "Let me just
take a peek real quick.
Yeah, it's not cracked.
We're good. I'm still cool."
-It was the slow turn around.
-You crushed that!
Okay, you crushed that.
JoJo, you're clearly
the better dancer.
Alright, why even compete
against each other
when we can do
one more together?
For this last dance
we pre-selected...
"the flying ponycopter."
-Oh, oh, it's on, baby!
-I'm gonna need a little help
for this one.
Thank you very much.
I am very excited.
-Uh-oh. What do you got?
-I'm very excited about this.
-That is beautiful, Jimmy.
-Thank you so much.
I wore this to work today
but made sure
it didn't get wet
with all the snow and stuff.
So here we go.
This is the flying ponycopter.
-That is incredible.
-Alright, ready?
Music whenever.
♪♪
-I lost my bow!
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
Oh, I don't know how you do it.
Alright.
You are a legend!
That is all the time we have
for "Tonight Show" Dance Battle!
Our thanks to JoJo Siwa!